Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Dr. Eli Merritt, who's a political historian
at Vanderbilt University and also editor of
the recently released collection of essays
The Curse of Demagogues Lessons Learned from
the Presidency of Donald J. Trump.
It's really great to have you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Thanks.
Good to be here, David.
Speaker 1: So I think one place to start would
be one of the big discussions that's now happening
in the aftermath of the Trump presidency.
And we're still waiting to know whether there
will be criminal charges or not.
And that may be part of this conversation.
Did we learn that the checks and balances
and safeguards put in place by the founders
were not strong enough?
If we had a president interested and willing
to do the things Trump did?
Or is that too bold a statement to make right
now?
Speaker 2: Well, I think we learned that lesson
in something else.
The the checks and balances that were put
in place by the founders back over 200 years
ago, as you know, with the Electoral College
and the powers of impeachment and conviction
and disbarment from future office.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 2: For very long, the Electoral College
has not worked.
And so the real truth is, soon after the Constitutional
Convention, 1787 ratification, 1788 political
parties became the dominant instruments of
our politics.
And also they became the dominant instrument
of checks and balances against demagogues
and authoritarians making it to the presidency.
So many things, I believe, failed in the years
2015 until continuing today.
But the most significant failure of checks
and balances, the most significant failure
of gatekeepers against demagogues who become
authoritarians is clearly the political parties.
Our political parties are woefully weak today.
And we can talk more about sort of the origins
of that.
But they became relatively emasculated starting
in the early 1970s when all checks and balances
at the nominating conventions were removed.
Speaker 1: Let's talk a little bit more about
that.
You know, I, I have not found anyone who disagrees
with me that Donald Trump could not have won
a Democratic primary.
Now, the reasons why people might disagree
with my reason is a little bit crude, which
is even though I'm neither a Republican nor
a Democrat, I don't believe Democrats would
have fallen for what Trump was offering, whereas
the Republican electorate, by definition,
did fall for it in that they made him the
nominee in 2016.
Is that a fair is that one of the differences
right now between the parties in terms of
the constituents?
And then are the differences between the constituents
greater than the differences between the parties
structures?
Speaker 2: I would say it seems very clear
right now at this point in our history that
the Democratic Party is the party of the Constitution,
the rule of law.
It is the party of ethical leadership.
No party is perfect and no and no.
And the entirety of the political figures,
politicians and any party are not ethical.
But I think it's a hard question to ask.
Democrats would never elect Trump, but I think
the most important thing to clarify here is
that we have descended somewhat into what
I like to refer to as a demagogue culture.
And I would not ever remove the possibility
that as the culture and the politics become
more and more fierce, that some liberal leaning
demagogue might come along who has similar
tendencies and angers and frustrations and
a personality as fierce as Trump's.
And if we get into this black and white thinking,
we think the other side is evil.
I do believe Democrats are also susceptible
to demagogues.
That's why what we do in one party is something
we should do in other parties.
And again, I think the most important area
of intervention, the most flexible point of
intervention, is the presidential nominating
system.
A lot of people don't know that very little
law governs, certainly not.
The Constitution governs political parties
and the nominating conventions.
Right.
So it's just a matter of the parties deciding
to make changes.
And they could do some interparty compacts
to use to to guarantee that each of them will
veto the emergence of individuals who clearly
do not support the Constitution, will not
solemnly swear to uphold free and fair elections
and the peaceful transfer of power and other
things.
Speaker 1: When we talk about.
Speaker 2: The Senate today, I think the Democratic
Party feels quite safe.
I really do.
I agree with you there.
But it would feel like hubris to predict over
the next ten or 15 or 20 years if we don't
clean some things up, that they could become
susceptible to demagogues.
Speaker 1: Oh, I agree.
I all of my assessments are as of today.
And, you know, when we hear people say when
Trump would say it, the State of the Union,
the U.S. will never be a socialist country.
It's sort of like never is a long time.
You know, maybe not.
I don't think next year there's not too many
socialists right now in positions of power.
But I think never and we want to be careful,
would never if we go back to 2016 a little
bit.
There's a lot of blame that is often placed
for how Trump how everybody failed to stop
Trump.
And sometimes it's, you know, James Comey
doing that extra press conference to talk
about Hillary's emails.
That was totally unnecessary.
That was the difference maker because it was
so close.
Or the media giving free publicity to Trump
is what allowed him to keep accreting to three
or 4% every time another primary candidate
dropped out.
That was the reason.
Or Democrats selecting a poor candidate in
Hillary Clinton is what's to blame now when
it's so close?
It's very hard to say.
One thing is to blame because any one of those
things could make a difference.
But given that, how do we assess the lack
of ability to have stopped Trump in 2016?
Speaker 2: I think that responsibility goes
around everywhere to our basic education system,
to the structure of our news media, as you're
saying.
And, you know, events like James Comey's relief
release of the emails or his judgment about
that are very significant.
But I would again posit that.
The only sure fire direction to go is for
political parties to block the emergence of
demagogues and authoritarians entirely from
entering the general election.
If I'm not mistaken, all of your questions
related to the general election.
And so there are certainly there are reforms
that can help to prevent a demagogue or authoritarian
within the general election from succeeding.
But they become for their base, you know,
religious figures and addictive figures.
So the most important thing that can be done,
if there were two things I would recommend,
would be, first and foremost, that the political
parties do their job and return to the party
having the power and the platform, having
the power and the candidate having to adjust
to the platform, which I think should begin
in both parties to have statements around
the Constitution and the oath of office, for
example.
The other thing where we woefully failed is,
is in the process of impeachment, conviction
and disbarment from future office.
The fact that after January six, after 45
years of witnessing Trump's bigoted speech
and damage to our our nation, that 43 senators
voted not to convict him either shows they
do not understand democracy, they do not understand
demagogues.
They do not understand that democracies can
fail or that they succumb to the cowardice
pathway of hyper partizanship.
So I think both play the roles of those are
the two most important places for intervention.
We could make an effort to at least educate
our politicians to understand these phenomena
better.
Speaker 1: You know, the interesting thing
about that is what you describe is what many
Bernie Sanders supporters say happened in
the 2020 primary, and they don't like it.
And what I mean by that is there is a story
that's told and there's degrees of truth to
all of these things.
Of course, that despite the people wanting
Bernie, the party coordinated.
I'm now searching into my memory.
But it was I believe Pete booted judge and
a couple other people getting out at the perfect
time to get Biden, South Carolina, with which
he built momentum to eventually become the
nominee.
We all know the story and a lot of people
are angry because they say now the people
should have the power, even if Bernie, whether
Bernie was destined to win or lose in a general
election, it should be the people, not the
party, that gets to decide.
You're saying something quite different, which
is actually the party needs to be the safeguard.
Speaker 2: I'm saying something completely
different.
I do, I believe, powerfully in representative
government and representative government,
as always, focus in representative government
with layers of democracy and layers of checks
and balances, has always survived and functioned
better than pure direct democracies.
So, yes, what I would actually like to see
happen in the reform I think would solve or
get close to solving the problem of demagogues.
Getting into the White House would be to let
the parties pick the presidential nominees
and let the people pick the president.
That is, in fact, the way it was done for
approximately 190 years in our country.
And we switched that in the early 1970s.
And I think we're living the consequences
of making that switch.
So I would have the people be very involved
in voting.
The people would vote for the delegates.
And hopefully by ranked choice voting, that
may be something you've covered on your program
or indeed indeed voting.
And then the delegates would go a stepwise
fashion to what used to be done county conventions,
state conventions and the national conventions.
I think today they would just go straight
to the national convention.
And they're they do their work just like we
elect delegates to the House of Representatives
in this country.
We elect them to go up there and do work,
which is to study the situation and make determinations.
So the first thing these elected delegates
would do is establish the party platform,
and then they would determine which of the
candidates who are involved actually will
fulfill the mission of the party platform
and not take over the party the way Trump
has done.
Most most countries in the world in variations
do something like I've just described.
Very few countries have direct primaries,
and I do believe they will continue to be
arrows in our sides and possibly fatal to
our democracy, meaning we will become a sham
democracy, not meaning we're going to engage
in ultimate civil war.
But it's a sad thing for me to think will
be a sham democracy where only democracy and
maimed and otherwise corrupt officials are
engineering everything behind the scenes.
Speaker 1: To look forward a little bit.
I'm curious about your assessment of what
is currently happening within the Republican
Party in the sense that we have these very
unusual circumstances in which this demagogue,
Trump, made a very early announcement that
he's running in 2024.
He has barely left his home since making the
announcement.
It's unclear really what the case is that
he's going to make for his next nomination.
A guy who hasn't announced anything, Ron DeSantis
is actually leading Trump in some polling.
The speakership fiasco from the last week
has exposed it's no longer just pro and anti-Trump.
Even within the Trump side, you've seen this
division.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Lauren Boebert
on opposing sides of that division.
Is something fundamentally changing here?
Speaker 2: I want to ask you to say more about.
Change something changing in the Republican
Party for the better or worse.
Is that what you're alluding to?
Speaker 1: Well, better or worse is more of
a value judgment.
But is the dynamic of it's the people for
and against Trump.
And it's that simple.
Is that dynamic changing where you're actually
getting even more fracturing, where the MAGA
side is now dividing?
Speaker 2: Well, I think what what Trump has
done is he has opened the mainstream of the
Republican Party in the nation, to some extent,
to what Nelson Rockefeller called back in
the 1960s.
This is his quotations, the lunatic fringe.
So I think it's hard to predict the 20 Republicans
who or so who were opposing Kevin McCarthy.
Yeah, I just think evidence a lot of qualities
in general that are very destructive to representative
government.
It is grandstanding.
It is not thinking of the best interests of
the nation.
It's a little bit of this lunatic fringe coming.
And so where things go, I am not certain.
I do know that we continue to have within
the Republican Party, the forces of Mitt Romney
have been somewhat profoundly weakened, I
should say.
Yeah.
So I don't know where the future of it is.
My real hope would be that at some point that
there will be a conservative party that splits
off from this Republican Party and that the
American people decide that this way of living
through demagoguery and lies and fear mongering
and hate mongering is not something they want
to do.
But we did that experiment.
Now we want to move on from it.
That's my hope.
So But I do think Ron DeSantis, clearly there
are criticisms of him.
He is not a demagogue.
If you just look at him speak, will determine
that the man is does not have the rhetorical
talents and destructive abilities of of Trump.
Some people worry he could become somewhat
authoritarian, but I've looked carefully at
what he's done in Florida and there's some
questions there.
Yeah, to my evaluation, the sentence appears
for the Constitution to be a much safer bet
than Donald Trump.
And Donald Trump, I think, is something's
happening for him.
I think he's becoming somewhat deflated by
what's happening.
And so hopefully he will be he could implode
and and become more dangerous to our democracy,
as we have seen with his comments about the
Constitution.
Yeah, but it's all quite unpredictable, as
I'm sure you agree.
Speaker 1: When we look in history, what sort
of events have catalyzed realignments in parties
where parties significantly shift?
Speaker 2: I think what what one discovers
I'm thinking of the beginning of the Republican
Party in the 1850s.
When you ask that there is a sense that there
is a national crisis, that the.
But someone needs to address.
And the Whig Party, for example, at that time
was determined not to be willing to go in
the direction that the Republican Party wanted
at that time mean it was clearly not an anti-slavery
platform, but it was an anti expansion of
slavery platform.
So a critical mass had been met there where
they felt the sickness has gone on in our
nation long enough and we cannot get traction
in these other parties.
And critically, back then, there was more
flexibility in the system.
Certainly there was not this entrenched money
in politics and the political industrial complex
that makes it so hard to form third parties.
Now that's a bit of a challenge and it's very
worrisome that third parties can be wonderful
things.
And again, you know, the Republican Party
was a third party.
Yeah, that rapidly grew and did well.
So I think it's crisis.
And so it could be that the current crisis
of demagoguery and authoritarianism and corruption
that we're beginning to witness now that could
in the hands of a Liz Cheney, for example,
become a catalyst for starting a third party.
And I think it should be done even if predictions
are it can't succeed.
We need to see people do the right thing and
make efforts in spite of the fact that there's
concern that we are a hopeless two party system.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I could not could not agree
with you more on that.
The collection of essays recently released
is The Curse of Demagogues Lessons Learned
from the Presidency of Donald J. Trump.
We've been speaking with the editor, Dr. Eli
Merritt from Vanderbilt University.
Really appreciate your time today.
Thank you so much.
Speaker 2: Great to be with you, David.